[Music]
he has been on all
a [ __ ] roll
transphobic sister who shoved me around
months ago visits says something like
meh will scare him
again
the seven years
beating the [ __ ] out of me regularly in
this house
this [ __ ] goes on record why are you
always Whispering because he's [ __ ]
scared
scared of everything
okay
transphobic [ __ ]
pictures
my sister beats me
in this house one day I'm gonna she's
coming she's coming she's coming
people and I just love how he's always
like
and then like they'll just walk right by
and they're like hey what's up buddy
exactly just walk right by him like they
just see him like he thinks he's stealth
every time she's over she always says a
lot of transpo oh hold on oh shut up
oh my God that was amazing that was
perfectly timed you couldn't do that bet
you couldn't do that better than that
happened
laughs
it's just weird he never manages to
capture these beatings I know I know
considering how much he films I mean if
I was getting my ass beat daily I would
finally just start rolling tape right
every day yeah you'd be like I'm gonna
get this I would be walking around with
a GoPro on my head yes
like it's a castle yeah exactly
how long have you guys been covering him
by now three years four years four years
four years like three to four years have
you ever seen anyone beat him no the
only beating we ever saw was him hitting
his brother over the head with a full
glass of red wine
just [ __ ] pigs and I just wanna
I just [ __ ] hate this place
I hate this place nothing works here
I've been here for seven years
what's the point of living
mushrooms if I knew we were going that
way bro specifically Dayton what's the
point of living like this every day it's
like
well he's only doing this until his
welfare Goodwill store takes off and
it's been his music career
it's not gonna happen remember they
already stole his idea oh that's right
I got a I got a new uh business plan for
Dayton sure I think I can solve this
problem sure Virgie let's hear it hear
me out hear me out let's hear it so he
takes his his uh his psoriasis droppings
right
this is dropping droppings it's an
amazing phrase and he bags those on up
right and he gets in touch with an
aquarium and he starts wholesaling it as
fish food
come on
Satan's leavings Dayton's leaving that's
gross that's the grossest thing I've
ever heard in my life 100 organic fish
food yeah it is
now how do we jar his ear peanut butter
for the koi
[Laughter]
are you trying to quit dabs well have we
got the product for you
oh I am not going to be smoking Dayton's
leavings
uh they're calling it dating
chicharrones ah come on Dayton pork
rinds those are disgusting
uh
not even at my segment yet and we're
already discussed it oh I know
transfer I have to shoot my house so
[ __ ] attention beat me for years
peace assuming my house you know when I
this whole family's gonna like die one
day and like he's gonna just be alone in
that house still ranting about all these
dead people yes that's [ __ ] his
[ __ ] ghosts [ __ ] ghosts haunting
me in this house
transphobic ghost
transphobic ghost ghost
[Laughter]
so [ __ ] dead on it's so bad I hate it
it's so good I hate it
[Laughter]
oh I was just sitting in my bed and the
gust of wind came in and all the dust of
my skin came up and it went oh boo
laughs
that's the thing he said something goes
he's just sing it's the skin dust
blowing around
he leaves his window open and a hard
gust blows through it looks like that
scene in Lion King when we're freaky
lets the [ __ ] flowers go in the Wind
blowing a [ __ ] dandelion
in the bathroom and I scratch them
scratched my neck and and the leavings
on the floor said get out
yeah he's gonna start seeing like Ghost
Notes written in his skin dust that'd be
[ __ ] hilarious
that's how he knows he's being haunted
because there's Footprints in all of his
leavings
and it turns out it's not a ghost it's
just his dad's been doing it
you try to try to scare him out of the
house
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
oh someone walked by
so did we ever get any like ancient
history on this guy dude
become crazy I've always liked this okay
so here's what I know from what I've
from what I've gathered
since he was a at least in his early 20s
he started being super weird but before
that he was just the norm like normal as
you could be kind of like a rock kid and
then he decided later on to become trans
I don't know what happened though I it
feels like a traumatic head injury I
have no idea but I do know this is that
he's known in the system we've talked
about it like you know the the social
serve you know the the the the the the
the the the the the crazy cops every
town has a crazy cops which are the
social service cops the gentle ones the
ones know you're crazy they want you to
kill yourself
uh they send those and they know him
they know him
um but I don't know specifically what
turned him nuts
with her husband
months ago
never Interruption we never had any kind
of real interaction since that point
that two of them cussed me out and
shoved me around they're both like
football players so is it like
large people and I'm like 120 pounds or
some [ __ ] which I'm tiny compared to
anybody in the family they're very thin
and everybody in the family thinks
possibly like just [ __ ] shove me
around
about me talking about the skinhead like
about you know accusatory Behavior he's
dead Jesus Christ really they've been
lying to cover their tracks
emergency room from a beating and their
words about the beating where it takes
two to tango those were the words about
the beating that happened that time yes
because normally in a normal family when
two brothers and this happens bro I have
a brother if you ever grow up with a
brother that's close to your age
Brothers [ __ ] forced around and fight
all the time like of course that is like
[ __ ] but the problem is with you it's
your little you know twink but Brothers
horse run all the time man I remember
once I accidentally gave my brother a
black eye so like it happens you know